there to be alive thank you very much
for watching the church today lisa yeah
what's happening little brother i almost
just died bro
i gave him a vapor pen of debt
with some girl scout cookies in there
god damn this [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
here's a little something for you guys
on a monday morning just so you don't
sit there like an orphan
delicious
and nutritious little vaping my lungs
are back i'm making a [ __ ] comeback
what's up dog where you been i haven't
seen you i know it's been uh it's been
almost 12 hours i know you have some
[ __ ] heavy duty podcasts last couple
days i want to thank miss pat
i want to thank al robles i want to
thank gabriellas for making a [ __ ]
special appearance that was uh huge uh
i've been thinking about that for a few
days about gabriel and how
you know they called out of the blue and
he went out of his way to come up here
you know he's a guy that doesn't need to
do [ __ ]
do you understand understanding people
he don't need to do [ __ ]
there's a lot of other [ __ ] comics
that never want to do [ __ ]
and this guy's got one of the biggest
things happening in his career any comic
could have in their career releasing a
movie a concert movie the film
and he came up here you know he ate a
little piece of cookie with us he
treated me with respect yeah he was very
nice and uh
i love him to death i really really
really love gabriel i'm very proud of
what's happening from and i love what's
happening from
uh and that's what it's all about we
told the stat camp the story of the
bloggie a lot of people
had never heard that or knew that that
gabriel gave me that blogging and i had
the energy from gabriel i wanted to do
something good with it look at me and
lee is still hanging out
four years later smoking dope i'm still
trying to kill lee oh my god oh my god
that vapor i don't know what happened
it just went in like fully into my lungs
and i was [ __ ] magnified it doubles
in there a little bit sometimes that's
what they said with like thai weed and
hash then when you hit it it doubled in
your lungs that's why you went [ __ ]
bananas oh my god but you were looking
good you were red your eyeballs were red
i loved it this [ __ ] eyeball looked
like it was gonna pop out of his head it
was it was like an hbo comedy special
i've never seen you laugh harder oh my
god plus he had a little bit of chiba
chew we opened up i want to thank chibo
chew
for putting back the [ __ ] green horn
in production as you can see we just ate
it like a savage it's over yeah it's a
[ __ ] memory jack oh i watched the
video that out robles podcast
i was
pretty much asleep when you called me
like the next day you're like don't
worry doggo it's just as high as you
were and i was like how were you [ __ ]
oh let me tell you some of those i
forget what's so kind cookies okay that
they sell over at noho organic the no so
kind
the 200 milligrams and they have 200
milligram uh
uh what do you call fudge okay you get
three pieces of [ __ ] fudge for ten
bucks i guarantee one of those pieces
could kill somebody
if you really wanted to kill somebody
just give i'm telling you i'm not even
trying to be funny that cookie is one of
the strongest [ __ ] things out there i
don't give a [ __ ] when anybody tells you
talking about the [ __ ] man here
you're talking about this is what i do
uh i'm not proud of it but this is what
the gap i fell into if i'm gonna stand
behind something i'm telling you right
now the so-kind cookie will take you to
places you've never [ __ ] been before
i see spots at night when i go on stage
some nights yeah spots i see [ __ ]
spots in the [ __ ] air i thought i was
going crazy i ate a half a cookie the
other night and i was in salt lake city
and i saw spots friday night on the
[ __ ] stage okay i'm not [ __ ] with
you people so kind cookies if you i
don't know who makes them i don't give a
[ __ ] i don't know what they putting them
i hope it's lsd
and uh that's it salt lake city off the
[ __ ] chain that's awesome again
duncan trust we've got a standing
ovation the second show
he was so [ __ ] funny this weekend
i've never got to see him live listen
man it's a it's a [ __ ] freak show
it's stand up
meets performance art
meets
this other [ __ ] which i can't describe i
mean his bits were great you know
but
he does his chant with incense on stage
and then little hobo looks like [ __ ]
joe rogan when he was a kid
the little little hobo he's bald he
looks just like joe rogan the first and
that's what happened the first night was
high
i i'm watching him on stage i turned
around and get water i turned back and
there's this little little hobo joe
rogan looking doll on this [ __ ] thing
uh and you could see he got better and
better with the sets you know like it
was just
uh something about salt lake city man if
you've ever been there been not it's a
beautiful [ __ ] place
i mean [ __ ] just beautiful were you
even like the main part of the center
center of the city just the places where
i've been to i've been to like ogden
i've been to provo i've been to like uh
park city
years ago you know this is two years in
a row i've been to salt lake city and
just from what i've seen and the people
are [ __ ] warm the people are [ __ ]
uh it's got a communistic
thing to it
you know people are very low key and you
could you know you understand
were there moments that came to your
show yeah mormons came to my [ __ ]
show you crazy no they don't [ __ ]
come to my show they stay home and [ __ ]
their 19 wives whatever the [ __ ] they do
but uh
they're very warm they party you know uh
i didn't know i'm used to going by the
bar and talking to comic people after
the show right and i couldn't figure out
where the bar was
and i went out there at one night
because the owner's like you have too
many people
and
you have too many people at the bar area
you can't really go out there because
it's too small you got to go outside so
we had to wait towards the very end to
go out and be like 10 people left just
to talk to them take pictures oh okay
and finally go where the [ __ ] is the bar
there ain't no [ __ ] bar
they have a little room with beers
that's it they sell beer three two beer
that's it no liquor no no vodka tonic
really so i had never been there before
so i'm really sorry for i thought i'd
just go out to the bar and talk to me
but they were all crunched up it really
wasn't no bar it was just a hallway
it was just a hallway so
duncan goes to the bar saturday and he
calls me he goes dog this is the
weirdest thing i ordered a glass of wine
yeah and they wouldn't sell it to me
unless i got an appetizer or a dish
something to eat
well and he goes he understood it and it
was 3.2 it's it's and to me i didn't it
didn't bother me whatsoever everything
all right over there lee i'm hearing
that buzz
maybe it's that [ __ ] chiba tree maybe
it is [ __ ] sucker
uh
it wasn't that uh
you just feel something you feel
something that people
aren't saying something you know like
they did but the interesting was the
shows the [ __ ] people were crazy i
mean the people that show up to these uh
debt squad shows are just [ __ ] out of
their mind okay oh yeah they're out of
their [ __ ] minds and i love it and i
love them even club owners club owners
can't handle it sometimes like who the
[ __ ] are these people these are real
people these are people who don't give a
[ __ ] these are people who work all week
want to smoke some [ __ ] reefer and
they want to yell and scream and i feel
it i don't give a [ __ ] what they do so
was it a better show because there
weren't that many drunk people
no who's not talking about that it was
just
a show no but i know it was a good show
people are always going to get drunk 3.2
baby
listen if you get 10 people and you give
them more [ __ ] ten beers and and five
of them are not they're still gonna get
[ __ ] drunk yeah just something about
hanging with other people and that
energy you know what i'm saying that the
whole energy
so
that that part of it was really
sensational but you do feel that little
that people are well behaved okay people
are under control like when you go to
the mall the [ __ ] mall was completely
different than anything i've ever seen
what was it like
just very controlled okay like everybody
walked kind of militantly i don't know i
don't know lee
but i liked it he like yeah come back
twice a year there and i would go back
to the festival i'd do all that [ __ ]
that's awesome but i didn't know they
only served beer till one
one o'clock wow alcohol till one you
know so there's little things but
that that doesn't mean [ __ ] to me
because i'm not gonna go out drinking
afterward anyway oh i know yeah so but
besides that it was all [ __ ] good man
that's awesome i loved it i [ __ ]
loved the [ __ ] well i'll see you
look at you yeah my wife this week what
movie did you go see we didn't see but
we were watching oranges is the new
black which is uh
it's interesting that you would miss pat
watched it because i always assume like
who's gonna why like if you were in
prison why are you gonna watch a prison
show but uh yeah we did that i moved
which is great and uh yeah you like this
new place yeah 80th [ __ ] move
hopefully it's the last one okay and
this place is into one bedroom yeah and
you got a living room like a savage yeah
like i said wife's got a little dining
area
a little bit not much so she got mad at
me because my couches are too big
i have a dining room table but it's like
kind of pushed up against the wall in
the back and she was like
when we move in together we're gonna
have like a nice like like like a whole
dining room area and i was like jesus
but it's uh it's funny i already met my
neighbors in this one and never you ever
catch yourself and you're like you're
being negative
and i
i was the first night i moved in and i
and i the neighbor on each side of me
had already had already introduced
himself and i met a neighbor from
downstairs and they were talking [ __ ]
about this one neighbor and i got i came
back into my apartment after i'd done
like the 18th trip to my car
and i was like feeling negative i was
like oh god i'm already talking to these
neighbors i don't want to talk to
anybody but then i was like wait i left
my last place because a neighbor
wouldn't talk to me
and and lied saying i was hitting his
car why am i upset that people are being
nice to me and saying hi so i feel like
i'd be like wait it's not that bad this
is a nice old lady and there's a there's
a lady who i don't know what happened
but she doesn't have any legs so she
just rolls around on a wheelchair and i
was just i thought of you immediately
but it was just
i don't know do you ever catch yourself
being negative about something like you
should be happy it's like the opposite
of what you hated it's like when you're
uh watching a sporting event you're in a
green room or something and the club
owner tries to be very nice and he keeps
coming in yeah asking can i get you
something after a while you feel like
saying [ __ ] don't come back in here
but
all the dude is trying to do is be a
sweetheart of a guy and offer you
something and then and then if you went
to a club and there was in the club
owner never showed up yeah then you get
pissed anyway it's weird how i catch
myself a lot a lot i catch myself going
why the [ __ ] am i mad about this guy's
trying to go out of his way what the
[ __ ] am i mad about this situation yeah
because you always go into a situation
at least i do very hesitant sometimes
yeah
and uh it's a bad way to go on a
situation you have to be more
open-minded but living up here in
[ __ ]
fake land you got to go into these
things like where is the shoe going to
[ __ ] drop you know when it's a bad
way to go into something it really is
you know it's funny when i wake up on
mondays people a lot of people ask me
man where do you get your energy from or
whatever you know what man when i wake
up on mondays like i went to bed last
night was this podcast finished with
miss pat last night about nine o'clock
yeah i had to go fill up my wife's tank
with gas for work today
i went home there was a parking spot i
basically went upstairs she was watching
something
i went in after on some decaf i mean
this was the i washed my hands yeah i
made a few notes in the notebook i went
out i got my coffee i spoke to her for
maybe 10 minutes
and she goes i'm going to bed and i go
i'm right behind you okay i cuz i got
home at like 10 and i called and you
were out gone gone and i fell asleep
and i woke up at 12 30 i had eaten a
bunch of [ __ ] cantaloupe and i woke
up at 12 30 and i must have pissed for
10 [ __ ] minutes
and i looked at the clock i didn't know
i go it's three in the morning and i'm
gonna be awake now because i just pissed
for 10 minutes
i looked at the clock and it was 10 to
12. wow and i already felt good like i i
felt refreshed i went right back to bed
and slipped a [ __ ] three got up again
to pee
i was a little thirsty i drank a little
water and i went right back to [ __ ]
bed
i got up to the alarm this morning i
mean usually on a monday morning i get
up before the [ __ ] alarm the alarm
woke me up this morning and i tell you
man i felt
dynamite this morning really great yeah
guys i have one really bad hitch and you
guys know what it is it's no sleep i'll
go to bed at 11 i'm walking around that
[ __ ] five and that's not good that
keeps weight on it doesn't you know you
don't get the proper rest you know so
i've been trying lately to really really
go to bed save two hours listen at night
i don't do dick guys i could lie to you
and tell you i'm trying to write i'm
trying to write and i make different
notes and stuff but when i wake up the
next morning it's not really what what i
wanted it right so there's two hours of
defeating the purpose why not just tap
out and go to [ __ ] sleep
you know tap i want to be normal i want
i like to [ __ ] stay up late guys i i
love to
smoke a [ __ ] vapor and maybe
drink a
hot chocolate and stay up whatever the
[ __ ] people do normal people do and stay
up until tv till two and watch let them
and i wish i could i wish i [ __ ]
could i would do it every night you know
your
day through sunday are kind of crazy
like when i when i went to austin i
experienced it because we wake up early
for this and then you take the [ __ ]
early early [ __ ] flight so we're
you're on the road by 4am usually and
then you can't sleep on friday because
you have to do radio you can kind of
sleep on saturday but then sunday you're
up at three in the morning yeah morning
again your body's uh and the good thing
is after governors this week i don't
have to go to lax the rest of the summer
oh [ __ ] i don't have to go to lax on
september 27th
unless they put me on that crazy tour in
august or whatever's gonna happen you
know i don't know about my knee surgery
yet because
it actually feels good i've been resting
it lately okay like these three days i
went to utah i didn't work out i didn't
do nothing jiu jitsu was so [ __ ]
rough last week
i went to jiu jitsu twice last week
and and then i went tuesday and thursday
usually i try to spread them out and it
was so [ __ ] rough on me like it's
it's not even the outer shape or the
bean
yeah it's being fat but it's uh
it's so rough when you go back to back
like my body couldn't i did kettlebells
and i walked on monday i went to jiu
jitsu on tuesday wednesday i just walked
with the baby i took a carriage and
walked all around to north hollywood
park and up and i walked to the [ __ ]
7-eleven that's like a two-mile walk i
walked pushing her
then thursday uh i went to jiu jitsu for
lunch and i got to [ __ ] tell you man
friday i was done
like thursday night i could feel my back
locking up a little bit you know uh when
i go to jiu jitsu that that
morning class that tuesday you know it's
like i guess it's like a basic jiu jitsu
class but we do a lot of warm-ups a lot
of rolls front rows [ __ ] judo rolls
which i can't do i just try a lot of
butterfly [ __ ] guard retention [ __ ]
then we drilled and they teach you
something and you drill it and you teach
three different things and you drill
different variations tuesday i didn't
roll i had to get the [ __ ] out i had a
three o'clock meeting i stayed till like
2 20 the class started at 12 30.
thursday actually rolled with a big kid
they got this big kid 25 years old his
name is joe he's puerto rican big
[ __ ] kid
he [ __ ] me up oh he [ __ ] me up he
[ __ ] me up so bad i was trying to hip
escape and i [ __ ] up my toe i thought
i was broken when i pushed it i'm like
oh no and i've got to tell you it's a
little sore so today i think i'm just
going to go to the epileptical and
[ __ ] uh hit the bag or maybe go to
kettlebell class i'll decide when i go i
didn't answer emails
so that's what i didn't do last night
okay i didn't answer emails i was going
to try to answer emails but i went with
the park with i went to the park with
the baby so but i tell you what puts me
in a good [ __ ] yesterday
when i got home
something happened with the the kitchen
was burning
i got home and terry something happened
in the oven okay and
the shot when i came out and i yelled to
terry terry got upset because i yelled
like what the [ __ ] there's a fire in my
house i've been home for [ __ ] minutes
already i'm agitated you know once i get
off the plane i take a shower
because those planes are [ __ ] filthy
yeah and something happened that i went
in and i caught super bad my favorite
cat got caught in the little gate the
baby gate okay you know he didn't cry or
anything i looked down like superman
what the [ __ ] are you doing
and then i pulled him out and he went
loose and a couple minutes later he was
crying
and i couldn't figure out what it was
and i got under there and i pulled him
out i touched him to make sure he didn't
break something
like what happened to my wife against i
just think he was scared you know
and this morning i got up and again he
was not hiding but he was behind one of
the pillars
so i had to pull the thing out this
morning and i grabbed him and had to sit
with him and hug him i didn't know if he
was mad at me i didn't know what it was
but just sitting there with my cat
and just him for a few minutes and tell
him i love him yeah put me in a [ __ ]
great mood
yeah because when i went out at three to
get something to drink i didn't see him
i usually see him and i went to bed like
what the [ __ ] is super bad god damn it
you know maybe he got cracked maybe he
thought i was yelling at him i wasn't
yelling at him i was yelling at my wife
i'm like what the [ __ ] is the house
[ __ ] burning and when i went out to
go into the little gate he got caught in
the gate and i was so i i think he
thought that i was yelling at him or
whatever i don't know you know
superman's as sensitive as i am
so i picked him up and i hugged him and
i told him i loved him this morning i
had to sit with him for like 10 minutes
and it was just really nice and all the
cats came over yeah it was five in the
morning there i am sitting on the floor
and i'm supposed to be on the computer
tweeting and here i am with these babies
on me and i'm hugging them and i'm
thinking to myself how [ __ ] lucky am
i i got stinky cats on me some people i
used to wake up and have nothing on me
i'd be by myself you know what i'm
saying yeah now i got these guys that
love me unconditionally these [ __ ]
animals you know and you think of how
simple and how stupid it is but how good
it made me feel yeah like i'm a new man
over that this morning and i wasn't i
didn't wake up in a bad mood or anything
i'm just saying that i was in a good
mood but hugging the super bad for a
couple minutes and having lulu come over
and lulu came over and bit his tail so
right away he's like looking at her i'm
like this is like having [ __ ] kids
it's just cats you know yeah so it was
just a really good morning sometimes you
don't know how lucky you are when you
have an animal man yeah that's awesome
yeah sometimes and i know you want to
get a dog you've been thinking about it
now at this new apartment they won't
they're supposedly not going to let me
but some people have them but i just
yeah i would love to get something
the dog just has so much it relies on
you for so much that i i feel bad about
the time i wish i wasn't allergic to
cats
but what are you gonna do you're not
that allergic to cat anyway well i i go
to your place and your places
is nice but you i mean you guys clean a
lot like every time i'm over there i see
the vacuum once
and it's just i mean
i'm not home that much and i i i know me
i'd probably let it go and
who knows maybe i'll get something
it's funny we were talking about uh
working on
i got a [ __ ] interesting i got two
interesting call out emails the last
couple weeks you know
people want to hear answers you know and
they yeah and sometimes people get rude
about [ __ ] yeah i got a lot of that this
week and i get pissed off at people but
usually sometimes people could hit me up
and they go hey man this is totally out
of love and respect i listen to your
podcast and they break it down i've been
listening to since day one when you told
felicia the story about this
so i think i had i bought your shirt
whatever no go i think i have a right to
talk to you about this the the
difference for me is i gotta and i
maybe it's one guy
if i go to your twitter and you're
saying nice things to people i'm like
okay he's he needs it well there's some
people like there's this one guy this
week who when you go to his page it's
either it was either a new page which
means he made it because i blocked him
or it was he's going down every list of
every comic saying something bad about
everybody so that pissed me off but uh
most of them are right it's just like
you gotta start doing and i did i took a
walk with paul this weekend
and uh she was like look at your back
and my back was like that was my shirt
my shirt was drenched take a shower
but it's uh
there's people out there that
they just want to ruin somebody else's
[ __ ] day yeah and the worst thing i
do is i always fall into their trap i
always call them a [ __ ] whatever
you all should just do is block them but
what you can do now is it's called mute
so that you they can tweet away you've
all english don't see it that's what i
did i don't give a [ __ ] what they do
it's just funny how there's people who
get up in one morning
make time to make a fake page yeah and
they go to you they go to 20 000 people
you see it when you look at that thing
hey
buffer why don't you go [ __ ] yourself
yeah hey dana white you're a conte joe
rogan [ __ ] you and you look at them and
go really so you took the time to build
the page
to be a [ __ ] little [ __ ] this is
what society has created for you to be a
little sneaky little [ __ ] and be cute
and soap people you got to feel bad for
that yeah it doesn't affect me at all
but then you have the people that go lee
i love you like a brother
you know i've been watching the podcast
for a year i was with you when you
juiced yeah those people you have to
listen yeah and this guy no this guy
just said that he thinks
that whatever my dieting was it's not
working that he's been listening to the
podcast he's a
a doctor he's a
chiropractor and his friend turned him
onto the podcast about nine months ago
when we had a doctor on here and he's
been listening to it and he says that uh
he sees my work ethic
and he goes i think you're working too
hard for the results that you're getting
because i think you should re-listen to
you you should re-look at your diet
again so i actually did what he told me
i got a notebook out again and it's
basically weight watchers and he goes
just for two weeks be as honest and as
brutal as you can and write down
everything you ate and take a look at at
the end of the day and also write down
what you did for a workout which is
basically weight watchers that's what
weight watchers it makes you claim
responsibility for what you're reading
okay now you look at it at the end of
the day
and i tell you what man it was pretty
[ __ ] scary really to be honest to be
very brutally honest and what's going on
in my house is yes there's no more sodas
and there's no more breads and there's
no more big extravagant meals okay
but there's
a child in the house now
so there's all these little [ __ ]
little snacks and treats
and you usually put one in your mouth
here one in your mouth there one in your
mouth here
those things add up yeah okay plus
sometimes yes i'm eating a [ __ ] piece
of fish but it's 15 ounces of fish the
diet calls for seven ounces of fish
so i'm eating double the amount even
though it's healthy you know what i'm
saying you're having a salad with it
it's double the you know it was just
little things i wasn't looking at in my
diet that he's right listen when i
started this thing i was 418 pounds
and i didn't at first i didn't i
neglected diet i just wanted and worked
out and then somebody said you should
tighten up your diets okay i didn't
drink [ __ ] six cokes anymore i drank
two cokes and one diet coke and i
actually lost weight with a minimal
workout hitting the bag and boxing
that's all i was doing then and swimming
that's all i was doing my wife is
introducing me to yoga a little bit but
for the most part i lost a hundred and
something pounds by boxing by getting in
front of a heavy bag every day and just
hitting it for 30 minutes
and
a certain rhythm it was just a rhythm
bam bam keep moving and it started with
three minutes and went up to six minutes
went up to nine minutes and then i would
either get on a bicycle
or the treadmill
and i would that's how i started and
then the other day i would swim for 45
minutes
wow and that's what i would do i would
just get in the pool and kick that's
where you lost the weight probably yeah
i kick i kick i kick i kick and then on
the way back i pulled
and after a couple times i put them
together i put the whole breath stroke
together you know that's how i did it
and i stuck the weight i didn't know at
that time there was no weight watchers
i was just hitting the bag
instead of eating three eggs
with a loaf of bread
i was eating three eggs with three
pieces of toast
you know little things like that i still
didn't know
about weight watchers and
i was just about
to tap out i didn't know what to do i i
said [ __ ] it this is not gonna work this
ain't gonna work i'm wasting my time
i'm 40 something i'm going to the gym
three times a week you mean all this
work and i've lost [ __ ] six pounds
because that's what happens yeah like
all this [ __ ] work and all i lost is
six [ __ ] pound
and then i read this article like a week
before christmas about how
we're confused that we could exercise
all we want unless we change our diet
nothing's gonna happen
and i decided to go to weight watchers
and it was [ __ ] brilliant guys it
really was brilliant i caught i caught
it i understood life is like county jail
you gotta eat like you're in the county
jail you know when you go to county jail
they give you one [ __ ] little piece
of meat loaf
you know and it works you make it
[ __ ] work for you yeah when i'm home
i eat you know my wife makes meatloaf so
i'll eat a piece of meatloaf with a
salad
first off meatloaf is like [ __ ]
horrible it's fattening as [ __ ] it's got
eight pounds per piece but because i'm
not eating the mashed potatoes and the
green corn and the [ __ ] cornbread
i think i could eat a bigger piece
so it's just little things like that i
wasn't looking at that that he was right
man by the way
while we're talking about good food i'm
going to tell you something about bad
food
so there's a little mexican place on
cold water
and riverside and it's called pete's
i've been going there for a long time
haven't you been there with me the
little mexican joint in the corner
window maybe very healthy very healthy
jerry rocha turned me on to it
and it's very healthy in there the
singer from the foo fighters goes in
there a lot oh wow okay
okay guys welcome in
oh [ __ ]
good morning good morning my love it's
dr tanya
how are you today good my love what's
happened how was the graduation
graduation is is a time of mixed
emotions and you will know what i'm
talking about sooner than later um you
know you go from from camp you can't
wait till they get out of the house
because they're driving you crazy to
crying because you're gonna miss them
and that happens like in five minutes
you know going from loving them to
hating them and loving them again
so uh it was beautiful it was beautiful
lots of happy tears
did she is she gone already
she's gone she is at beach week and i
know after we graduated high school we
went to you know the jersey shore for a
few days and these kids go to ocean city
uh maryland for about a week and i have
to say it's probably just one big drunk
fest so i'm trying not to not think
about it too much but she's a good kid
and she's out there stretching her wings
a little bit
tanya messina let me tell you something
uh
that's funny you said that so
when you graduate the eighth grade what
year did you graduate seventy eighty-one
uh eighty eight from mckinley school and
who was your eighth grade teacher
wally linsley was he still the mayor
then
he was the mayor and my eighth grade
teacher
and
i'm not going to say too much more about
that
you know what you know which one is
dealing oh yeah yeah no i remember he
got indicted and stuff he was a great
guy i loved wally lindsay when he take
you for [ __ ] eight day trip
well he took us down the shore he took
us to his beach house believe it or not
um we all went for the day down to like
i don't know where it was long beach
island or something i don't know what
was it wasn't an official you know
school trip i can't imagine it was but
we went on a school bus
and we had a lot of fun
so much fun for eighth grade it's funny
because in the eighth grade we went to
philadelphia and betsy ross's house and
all that [ __ ] remember you all do that
and the nutcracker sweet i went there
with your sister and all those clowns we
took a bus on the way back we stopped at
callahan's
and that's the winter trip that's the
big winter trip and then for the summer
trip they went somewhere where there was
water i like to say like uh what's the
place in jackson new jersey
great adventures oh great adventure
great adventure that's why i think they
went for the day
but
you guys went down like a show like
overnight type trip [ __ ] we got jin yeah
it wasn't overnight it wasn't overnight
it was definitely like a beach house
like on a lagoon it must have been his
house and i just remember like hanging
out on the dock and you know
you know sneaking a few cigarettes and
stuff like that so and you drank it must
not have been a very educational school
trip you drank in the eighth grade
uh i did i did i learned from the best
let me ask you something was he still
hanging around with a guy named jordan
then when you were in the eighth grade
do you remember i remember him hanging
out with the cheerleading coach mrs
cesto that's what i remember
the cute little chubby girl
no no no she was little tiny girl with
it with a big rack yes
and she used to hang out with gina
giacona
exactly everybody thought her and gina
were loving it up
that's right
i didn't know what was happening but he
used to have a little the guy that did
all his cleanup work was a guy with a
wig his name was turk jordan he was a
really creepy looking guy he took me
chucky mcbreen and whitey o'donnell to a
basketball game and he got into a fist
fight
that's a [ __ ] craziness that it was
the mayor's aide he was the mayor's aide
at the time
i don't know if you ever met him and
that doesn't really matter yeah i don't
think i did i don't think i did but
talking about mckinley school coco i
want to tell you that your reader your
listeners have a really soft place in my
heart because after i was on your show
last time my um my blog had the best
week ever i mean you tons and tons of
your listeners came to my to my site and
i very much appreciate that so i gave
them a little treat today on my site
today is a story about how we met in
mckinley school and it's a funny story
so if they want to learn more a little
an early story about uncle joey they
should check it out today thank you
and i don't know if you remember how we
met so you might need to read it too i
don't remember tiny messina i don't
[ __ ] remember
i remember i was little i was like in
fourth grade yeah because i was uh two
or three years older than you
right right and you came into my
classroom that's all i'm going to say
you have to read to find out the rest
okay no it's uh
very interesting i've been talking to
you lately and it's been bringing back a
lot of memories from that
that neighborhood the reason why i
didn't go on the eighth grade trip to be
honest with you it was the year anthony
died
so i was already done i said you know
what i'm not going on that class and i
registered for a
five-star basketball camp and it was a
long snow year
so we went to school a lot longer we
didn't graduate until later on but i'm
really happy that you called because we
were talking about something that some
guy
wrote me a note and we were talking
about how when you get in shape
that it's a lot more
you know dieting than going out there
and running hills you know like to lose
the [ __ ] weight so i'm happy that you
called what do you have for us today dr
tanya on our health
well we'll definitely talk about about
the weight loss thing if you want for
sure um but i also want to just give you
a couple little blurbs about childbirth
and
you know it might not be something that
you that your listeners are dying to
hear about but there's something very
troubling that's happening and either
either your listeners or parents or
they're going to someday be parents
and i feel very passionately about this
that the u.s united states has just came
out literally in the beginning of may
this year we're the only country in the
entire world whose maternal mortality
rates are increasing what that means in
real language is that mothers are dying
giving birth in this country and that
those rates are increasing only in this
country everywhere else in the whole
entire world
fewer mothers are dying in childbirth in
this country more mothers are dying in
childbirth and what is the result what
is the reason why they say it's crazy
they're saying they're saying you know
that because we're having babies at
later ages here and because we have such
bad diets and a little exercise so that
kind of ties into your reader's question
that we're sicker going into childbirth
i personally happen to think that
another factor
is that we are medicalizing birth you
know birth is not brain surgery birth is
a natural process that doesn't really
need anybody to help it women can
literally squat and have a baby
but in this country because you know you
can make money off it and you can put
them in a sterile hospital room and make
it a procedure
and you can control it we like to do
that and i think the more you mess with
it
the worse it is out of 46 countries that
are industrialized you know people that
have a really good health care system
where do you think we are on the list if
one is the healthiest and 46 has the
worst
and that's overall health
36
yeah we're 31st so you're close but
that's that's that's a travesty i mean
don't you think that we have more
hospital literally we have more
hospitals
more doctors more research and
development than any place else in the
world and there are 30 30 countries that
are healthier than us we're doing
something really terribly wrong coco and
and it's very disheartening to me
because i see it every day in my office
i see these people come in and they're
sick and i see these moms come in and
they're getting cesarean sections 35
percent of moms have cesarean sections
that's horrific because only 10 should
be having them
so i have a really hard time with that
we're on par guess who we're on par with
health-wise for maternal mortality we
have the same rate as iran and
afghanistan
so so if you told your wife i want you
to be in the best place to have a baby
you're a senator iran in afghanistan or
you wanted to be someplace where your
mamas are not dying i mean that's crazy
isn't it
that is [ __ ] crazy i'll tell you
uh one of the scariest parts of my life
was when my wife was recently pregnant
that was one of the scariest phases
because i knew a thousand things could
go wrong you know i had i have a belief
that nothing was gonna go wrong
but i was very scared for her especially
at her age i had gone online
and read about childbirth women over 40
and i had to [ __ ] shut the computer
off i started bawling
i was i changed you have to yeah yeah
you have to
so i didn't know that this mortality
rate went and is it because i mean you
also mentioned that women aren't as
healthy going in
right because number one they say we're
older and also you know to your against
your reader your readers um and you're
the guy who wrote you in to his point
you know
you were heavy we're not we're sedentary
we're not active our diets are crap
and
this is a very physical activity labor
means work right it's work pushing a
baby out did your wife push a baby out
or did you have a c-section my wife
pushed it out
so you saw that right yes yes i didn't
think it's crazy right it's [ __ ]
crazy it is one of the craziest things
you'll ever see but
one of the i don't know i i want to say
beautiful but i don't want to sound
cliche
but it's something that
everybody should see one time
it's uh
when i had my first child when i was 20
something
i just [ __ ] passed out i couldn't
handle it and now i know why i passed
out i didn't pass out
because of my fears i passed out because
something didn't i don't know
i didn't see the beauty in it when terry
had the child
i was in a better place with my life and
i handled it you know the only thing i
saw a little bucket with blood
and i kind of freaked out but i looked
at her i looked at her and i saw her
transformation right in front of my
[ __ ] eyes like the wolf man with no
3d or 6g or none of that [ __ ]
it was uh it's
i don't know i don't want to sound like
one of those [ __ ] guys but i saw
something different in that room
i i think that's a beautiful thing that
number one that you felt it number two
that you can say that because a lot of
guys think it's you know no big deal to
macho it's no matcha [ __ ] you are
seeing you're saying your wife's power
in that moment that's her power that is
what she what she was meant to do it's
uh
i hate to say that i [ __ ] hate to say
that
i hate that statement tanya messina but
i gotta tell you something i feel it
myself
because i know terry i knew terry for 12
years before that there's times i have
problems with terry you know why because
terry's a little like me she's a [ __ ]
panty ass
and she's tough you know she'll say this
wild [ __ ] to me she'll say wild [ __ ]
you know and it drives me [ __ ] crazy
but then again i say wild [ __ ]
but ever since she's had this child
i saw what she was put on this planet to
do
like i really like when she was working
all those weeks
and working full-time i had to sit it
down and go looking man i'm looking at
it from the outside in you're [ __ ]
defeating the purpose
you have no idea what you're
you're confusing here i go you've put
away money
i go on the road
sit at home i don't give a [ __ ] to her
it was a different thing it was like a
different monster
and now i see her her hair looks
different
her eyes look different
you know it's it's an amazing
transformation to see a woman become a
woman
like a [ __ ] woman like to see why
whoever the [ __ ] put around this planet
the indians the martians god
the jewish guy why what the woman was
meant to really kind of do
i know a lot of women are going to hit
me back and go joey i don't want to have
kids how can you say something like that
no
i'm telling you when it came to my wife
oh my god
i saw who the [ __ ] she became in 10
[ __ ] seconds
yeah you're right and i love listening
to you talk like that because i see it
i've been with you know probably a
hundred patients as they give birth and
i cry my eyes out every time because
it's a beautiful beautiful thing and i
think the medical system in this country
unfortunately takes that away from a lot
of women
when we slice them and dice them i and i
know that some women need c-sections i
get a lot of hate mail because of this
and i'm okay with that because this is a
really important subject you know ten
percent of women actually five to ten
percent of women need a c-section for
emergency reasons
but in this country we give 35 percent
of the women c-sections and when you do
that because it's inconvenient or
because the doctor you know has better
skills with c-section than delivering
them vaginally
you're taking that moment away from
women you don't get that high you don't
get that transformation in that moment
when you cut a baby out
and that's
it's tough i'm gonna tell you something
tiny messina and
partly it's the woman who's giving birth
fork also because they turn childbirth
into a [ __ ] wedding
see i went through childbirth in l.a
with my wife and my wife is like me
she's no nonsense she just wanted to
spit the kid out she was 42. i went to
the doctor's meetings where i went to
those little group meetings where you
spin a [ __ ] ball around and all that
[ __ ]
and
but i also went through that with my
ex-wife in boulder
now boulder has all these [ __ ]
gentiles
so you could either have the child at
the hospital or you could have the child
at the child birthing center
and at the child birthing center it's
natural there's indians playing the
violin
you know people wash your feet they're
eating croissants
and the guy's name was dr misoka
dr masoka was six foot seven
290 pounds from brooklyn he looked like
a [ __ ] gangster and his wife there
were a combo team
all right his wife was this beautiful
little petite white woman
you looked at them and said what the
[ __ ] happened here but everybody went to
dr masocha because a woman was dying a
mother was giving birth and she was
dying on the hospital bed and musalka
yelled at the staff and brought the lady
back to life
so musaka was like a no nonsense like
get the [ __ ] up [ __ ] you know like he
used to say [ __ ] to women that women
would stop going to him and they felt
insulted by him but he was he had such a
great reputation
do you follow me that they put like he
they would put up through it like my
buddy called me he was like my [ __ ]
wife went to masocha my wife put on 40
pounds and misoka looked her in the face
and said it's okay baby i like my women
a little heavy myself right if they fall
i could catch him he was torturing women
with those sayings but he was so good
that was his reputation he had saved the
mom
on the bed so he would always give you
the birthing center
or you know you had the option of
the hospital my wife who was a granola
eating [ __ ] momo
picked the birthing center tanya messina
she tapped out within 15 minutes
did she really she had to send her over
to the hospital yeah she went in there
with the sandals on
and the mudwa that [ __ ] woman that
comes with you
and some spiritual advisor
and some lady with gluten-free biscuits
and that [ __ ] ended in about eight
minutes she was yelling and screaming
they had to give her an epic epidural
block and they took it to the main
[ __ ] hospital and that was the end of
that she lost face
the hippies didn't want her ever again
it's i have to say it's tough i mean
again they caught labor for a reason i
walked around for 38 freaking hours with
my first no drugs walked up and down the
hallway in the birthing center i ate a
whole freaking watermelon literally i
had a whole watermelon
when i was in labor with her and i
pushed her out standing up right onto
the floor
oh my god no drugs i
no drugs no drugs so she was 38 hours my
second one was an hour so i kind of
averaged out you know whatever 18 hours
19 hours
my wife this time went in sunday at one
and she had the baby tuesday
at like seven in the morning but it
wasn't like all pushing and whatever we
just sat there and watched tv and we
[ __ ] and i left for four hours and i
went and got high and came back
yeah now let me tell you what it's like
i'm gonna i'm gonna walk you through a
little exercise here coco what it's like
to have a baby in a hospital bed with an
epidural so
i'm gonna tell you that i'm gonna put
you on your back i'm gonna put your feet
up in the air and those stirrup things
i'm going to make you numb from the
waist down
and then i'm going to tell you to take a
poop
is that going to be easy is that going
to be hard that's going to be [ __ ]
disgusting
right it can be disgusting but it's
gonna you can't even imagine taking a
poop on demand when you can't even feel
your yourself from the waist down right
no that's what it's like to push a baby
out when you're laying on your back with
an epidural
and you don't feel nothing
nothing
and people say i'm crazy for walking
around and having a baby standing up or
squatting down it's like well how do you
pushing a baby out coco this is the
bottom line pushing a baby out is just
like taking the biggest crap of your
life
oh jesus christ
that's yeah and if you're numb from the
waist down
you you know it's hard it's hard to it's
hard to know how to push and how long to
push and when not to push and all that
stuff so
you know when you when you're numb
that's why a lot of these women start
needing interventions they start needing
those forceps and that vacuum thing have
you seen the vacuum thing they pulled
the baby out no i don't want to [ __ ]
see it either i don't want to [ __ ]
see a vacuum
i saw the i saw the spoons when they
when they give you the the stork bite to
the head
and they suck yeah that's that's the
forceps
oh my god yeah the vacuum thing is they
literally put a suction cup they go up
your wife's vagina and they put a
suction cup on the baby's head really
tight
and then the doctor leans back with all
his muscle and pulls the baby out jesus
that's good for the baby and that's why
kids have pointy ears when you see those
little martial looking [ __ ]
like mike chicarelli
i think darren reagan even had a pointy
ear god bless his soul i know darren a
little wrestler oh my god i was thinking
uh
i'm doing governors this weekend in long
island
and yeah i saw that i saw that are you
not are you going for sure or not you're
not sure yet no i'm leaving i'm leaving
i gotta go i gotta go it's thursday
friday saturday but it's funny regina
gordon's son is coming to see me
regina gordon passed when she was 49 and
she died two years ago
and
he hit me up on facebook and we've been
kind of
friends you know on facebook and he hit
me this week and he asked me if you
could come see me and i'm sitting here
going it's amazing tanya that now i'm
dealing with my friends i grew up with
kids
with their kids that's amazing
in the blink of an eye and i bet don't
you i bet in every city you perform i
bet you have someone that you know from
north bergen coming to those shows is
that true yeah pretty much lately oh
they hit me up whether it's
you know whether it's a friend or a
child or a you know a spouse or some
connection i would imagine that every
show because i know when i go to see you
there's always someone there yeah
there's an acquaintance or something
it's really weird that we're to that
level in our lives where he's going to
come and ask me about his mom you know
he's going to go with my mom like when
she was growing up you know whatever and
um
it's it's just the weirdest thing this
phase of our lives we're going into your
daughter graduated you know
jesus tanya it went [ __ ] fast
blank of an eye coco blink of an eye i
mean i kissed took her by the other day
going to beach week and she's not coming
home for a month she goes from the beach
in maryland to the cayman islands i want
her life right she goes to the cayman
island with her boyfriend and his family
and then get this she goes to australia
new zealand and hawaii so i'm not going
to see her for a month and you know i'm
happy so happy for her that she's
confident
and adventurous and she gets these great
experiences but i'm sad like you know i
love my kid you know moments i want to
you know ring your neck but of course
you love your kid she's your life she's
your heart
and the fact that she's now basically
launched she's starting her own life
right now it's it's it's happy and it's
sad
i can't even [ __ ] imagine you know
i think of us uh running around those
woods and
up and down to union city and you know
we watch your girls back you know we
always watch you guys and
you think of our kids how to be in that
situation where you let your daughter
run around north bergen with us when we
were kids saints doing what you were
doing at 13. oh my god coke i remember
following you guys up the hill by the
cemetery going to the what's the name of
the store on by the cemetery the spec
store no the chinese yeah exactly there
was no no
that was what was the chinese dragon
grocery dragon grocery i took lee i took
him into the dragon grocery he's not
there i was like i was like how old are
you in like fifth grade you're like
like 10 11 12 years old are you kidding
me i mean going up the hill
i just i just my head spins with the
memories of what you know hanging out
the soccer field
you know everyone's got a little
something in their back pocket whether
it's you know little booze or a little
something else and
we were babies would you would you let
your daughter go out with us today if
you knew would you let her in that
environment but look what you became
from that neighborhood tanya that's the
other question
part of who you are
is from what we saw and learned in that
little [ __ ] six corners of the world
in the woods in the woods
i know that i know that it makes you
stronger because you have to be street
smart right you have to be tough
and you know i i definitely i don't i
don't invalidate it i think it
definitely made me who i am today made
me successful you know it's all all
roads lead to today
a hundred percent but you wonder why the
sad part is the people that didn't make
it out at all or the people that didn't
make it out successfully or happily
that's what makes me sad like how come
you know
i think we have a great life you out in
l.a me here and we we are we have it all
right we have family we have health we
have beautiful kids we have great
friends jobs we love so we we do have it
all we all live in a dream but there are
a lot of people like that are where
we're from and they didn't they weren't
so lucky yeah they got stuck but guess
what i was stuck for years also tony
remember i'm 51 i was stuck for [ __ ]
15 years
for 15 years i was stuck on a drug that
i was stuck on a drug and i was i had
fear and i had confusion and anger i had
a lot of anger and when you add the
drugs to the [ __ ] anger that turns
into a
so it took time it takes time to work
through things
i guess to the the best thing to say is
that they never really work through
things
that's the only way i can figure this
out how some people just get stuck and
some people do it in the beginning of
their lives
and some people do at the end of their
lives i you know i don't get it
i don't understand i could never ever
ever again put a line of coats on my
nose not because just because i i went
through it already
i went to that state already i went to
that state i visited i took pictures i
bought souvenirs i did everything i went
there already you know i could never do
a lot of the things
and when i hear of people our age still
snorting coke in north bergen
it kills me
yeah it kills me it kills me about uh
the reason why i brought what i was
thinking about regina he used to date
houston dave kurt
regina was a beautiful girl she only
flynn conti kurt and and ed connors all
those guys are tense those are tens
those guys those men were tens they
could be on any cover of any [ __ ] gq
glenn conte kurt di lorenzo and his
heyday and eddie connors they could be
on the cover of any magazine at any time
they just blew it definitely they just
blew it i saw a picture eddie connors
and facebook from 20 years ago he looked
like a hollywood star do you know who
that was eddie connors
oh definitely oh for sure the fireman he
was a fireman this guy looked like a
[ __ ] hollywood star that's who that
regina dated
and i think a guy like kurt who we were
cousins with we were family i ate in
this house i lived in this house
he's m.i.a how did that happen tonya
i know that breaks my heart and i had i
mean he was like the brother i never had
he was always right you know
you try you try so hard to help someone
but you really can't you can't rescue
someone they have to rescue themselves
no what happened there i mean this kid
went to college this kid
made millions this kid 30 years ago was
on top of the world
to see a kid now that they say that
doesn't have shoes
he walks around yeah it's heartbreaking
it's uh i don't know is it luck i mean
so what so what so what's what's the
determining factor you know we don't
have to get all psychoanalytical but
it's a little bit of luck is it hard
work is it just you know i don't know
but i'm grateful for what you have
worked and the stars definitely have to
[ __ ] align but it's got to do with
you and you going one morning you're
waking up and going this doesn't work
for me no more this [ __ ] doesn't work
for me no more i'm gonna try this this
that's what we're just talking about
here that i've been stuck between 300
and 309 for the last 90 days
before that i was at 316 [ __ ] pounds
and i lost the weight after the
testosterone but for the last month i'm
a zigzag in between that and some guy
sent me a a an email saying that i
should write down my diet again like uh
like uh
weight watchers so i did it the last two
weeks and i looked at it and i saw what
i was doing wrong yeah i don't eat bread
no more and yeah there's no soda in the
house and i exercise
but my wife has a child now we have a
child and she's buying children's food
there so she started buying those
[ __ ] cheese puffs
every time i walked by the counter i ate
two [ __ ] cheese puffs
by the end of the day you eat 16 cheese
puffs that's 300 [ __ ] calories that
you thought you walked off on the
eucalyptical machine
right now and let me ask you this do you
also finish the food on her plate
because that doesn't mean you think no
no i don't need the baby
no she eats all [ __ ] non whatever
food my wife gives it like food with no
[ __ ] flavor she's starting off early
into the gentile world the other day i
gave her cuban rice and chicken with hot
sauce my wife had a heart attack but she
bit something hot and then she started
crying my wife said i don't know what
the [ __ ] happened
but no no and i'm trying to really you
know i gotta go for this colonoscopy now
you got me all scared i gotta fart and
they're gonna
turn the lights out and [ __ ] put a
camera up my [ __ ] but these are the
things you got to do tanya to make it to
the next level you know i want to live
to i'm 70 now i want to see this girl
graduate high school
of course you do no and you have to do
the right thing the colonoscopy don't be
scared because you're in you know la la
land they really do it's nice medicine
they give you but i'm telling you where
they give us you're going to not only
fart yourself you're going to hear
everyone else's parts around you
where they give you the medicine do they
give me intravenous
they probably they'll give you an iv and
it's like a twilight so it's not it's
not general anesthesia but you won't
remember a darn thing they say you have
the best sleep of your life when you get
a colonoscopy it's only like 15 minutes
you feel like you slept like 12 hours
yeah but if you sleep the camera's up
your ass and they see you they're naked
your asshole's wide open
listen finally if you come over my house
and you fall asleep and i play with a
camera up your [ __ ] and i know you're
definitely gonna be asleep for 45
minutes i'm gonna put other [ __ ] up your
[ __ ] not my dick but you know maybe a
tic tac who knows
you know i'm gonna have a good time with
your [ __ ] what the [ __ ] lee what's
happening over there you have any
questions for dr tanya lee no the child
birth thing was crazy because i i
remember you during that time
and you you didn't kind of i don't know
if it hit you then or you just didn't
want to talk about it but like you were
definitely more on edge during that time
then after the after mercy was born you
were like
yeah i mean i read that thing i i went
crazy like
thinking about that like
and
now it's kind of crazy because mercy's
such a beautiful girl but when when
your wife comes to you at 43 is any part
of you like it's not safe to have the
kid
i couldn't tell her that there was no
way i was going to tell her that that it
wasn't safe because i didn't even want
it up in the universe right i just went
online to see if there was anything i
could do to help her okay walk with her
you know there was some different things
i could do at the age of 40 with the
women walk with her go swimming with her
what i could do to help her out and i
saw all these negatives
and that's what put me on [ __ ] edge
you know that's all it was i'm sorry if
i
no no no but it wasn't it was just it
was interesting and i mean it's horrible
to even think about but i mean i i just
cuz like
we had miss pat here last night who had
a kid at 12. i can't imagine having a
lady here last night that had a kid at
12 tanya oh geez
[ __ ] 12 by the time she was like 14
yeah two by the time she was 14
by a 25 year old dude
yeah that's crazy stuff that's crazy but
i mean but would you ever think that
that women like you think of women
balance
dying in childbirth you think that's
like the colonial days you think that's
like in africa
no people are dying in this country
like i said it's gone up 136 since 1990.
that's crazy so is it because like
there's complications during the
c-section that wouldn't have been there
during the natural childbirth is that
like is that mostly definitely
that's definitely i won't say it's most
of it i don't want to give incorrect
information but you know when when the
world health awareness organization says
that five to ten percent of women need
these sections and we're doing 36 of
them and the world health organization
also says doing more than 15 does way
more harm than good yeah that's a that's
one of the reasons why women are dying
in childbirth it also has to do with
again being unhealthy going in i mean
you can't have high blood pressure
diabetes
you know be obese and and push a baby
out or not have a complication so so
that definitely has an effect too we're
generally less healthy but i think we
interfere too much having a baby is not
a medical procedure it's natural you
should just let it happen it doesn't
need help it just needs you to not
interfere with it i mean it's proven
when the [ __ ] taxi cab driver helps a
woman have a baby
you know yeah every [ __ ] day you read
about a taxi crab a cop a [ __ ] bum
somebody a lady didn't make it and she
gets down they get hot water they get
some towels and the baby spits it out
right there in the [ __ ] cab i mean it
happens all the time i mean it's easy
for me to talk about because i've never
come close to experiencing it but it
sounds kind of like what what i know
personally is the problem with me losing
weight
it's like you want the easier way out so
it seems like maybe the women are are
saying oh i want the nicest i want to
feel anything which i can understand why
you wouldn't want to feel that coming
out of you but i mean it seems kind of
like there's no easy way around they
just gotta do each guy do it now what
you're saying but these are the same
women i gotta say this these are the
women who say i don't wanna feel pain in
childbirth or i wanna schedule a
c-section so i'm numb and i know when
it's gonna happen these are the same
women who were who were getting freaking
brazilian bikini waxes walking around in
like six inch heels and doing triathlons
those three things hurt like hell okay
but you don't want to push a baby out
like i don't get that i i call [ __ ]
on that for sure let me ask you this
because i'm looking at this from a
different angle now so let's say terry
went and had the baby
naturally boom hospital a couple [ __ ]
people they spit it out one night stay
comparison to cesarean what what's the
difference in cost
um approximately double to triple okay
so there's your answer right there so
i'll adopt because i'm gonna tell you
something
my wife mentioned it to me cesarean she
i know she mentioned it and then she
said no because her girlfriend had a
cesarean
and the girlfriend that had the
caesarean
is a chick that uh
is like a model
type chick
she carries guns
you know she's very at the gym every day
and she had a cesarean because she
didn't want a scar i don't know what the
[ __ ] the deal was so you're absolutely
right on the type of women that do it
she carries a piece she's a model
she works out you should have seen this
girl at childbirth she was ripped to
shreds from working out
she went to the gym twice a day while
she was pregnant
but she had the caesarean
yeah and that's an elective cesarean and
again i'm gonna get hate mail and you
might too i mean people say i needed the
c-section and if someone needs a
c-section because their baby is in
trouble or they're in trouble that's
what they're there for i have no problem
with that and we're very blessed to have
c-section to save a mommy and the baby
but when i'm talking that a doctor says
you know a doctor doesn't want to get
called at six o'clock on a saturday
night to go deliver a baby vaginally
isn't it nicer to say well do your
c-section on a monday morning this way
if you have any complications i can see
you monday through friday i have my
weekend to myself now i don't think they
they go through that calculated but when
you can control it and go like oh i got
i got four patients that are due this
week
you know i'm going to be up all night
i'm not going to get sleep my daughter's
graduating you think they don't want to
do a c-section
you know a scheduled plant cesarean they
do or even an abduction where they put
them on into labor you know with drugs
they want to control it they people in
hospitals like to control things and
when someone's dying of cancer they
should control things when someone gets
hit by a train they should control
things when you're having a baby step
away
[ __ ] dr tanya on a monday [ __ ]
morning
giving out rules i like it tanya i got a
few things to say about that don't i i
know i like it i like you have to work
today you know what's your schedule no i
work on thursday mornings that's that's
when i see patients and the rest of the
week i write i write on my blog and i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna openly solicit
your listeners to go to go to my blog
doctortonya.com
d-r-t-a-n-i-a check me out read about
uncle joey
the story about when i met you when i
was in fourth grade so i write every day
i go do yoga every day i did yoga on the
farm my friend has a farm i did it last
night for an hour and a half it was
beautiful outside with the crickets
i take care of my kids and my husband
you know breakfast lunch and dinner just
do you know i do the wife thing i do the
laundry the cook and the cleaning
and i have a nice very balanced life i'm
very blessed i get to see patients i get
to educate patients online
i get to take care of myself
life is good
i'll tell you ever since i
re-communicated with you my life's been
a little better you're uh
your voice is very soothing and you're
uh
and tonya messina not only did somebody
hit me up the other day and tell me
about that i should check out my diet
again
somebody hit me up three days ago and
right off the
bat said bluntly
that you should get in touch with your
daughter again when i thought about you
and it's really weird that you called
today because i didn't answer the email
uh i was going to talk to you about it
because we had the discussion in the car
that day and it really hit home with me
but i didn't want i think i when i left
there i left there i think i didn't want
you to think that i had given up or i
hadn't
hit her up in the last few years like i
said i hit her up the last three years
in a row two were on her birthday and
one was before the school year
and i got no responses three years in a
row so i just moved on with my life
no you have to because that's like
banging your head against the wall right
doing the same thing and expecting a
different result that's what insanity is
so you have to you have to take care you
have a wife and a baby now you got to
love them
but you know i just
having kids and you know looking at your
baby girl that babies you know girls
need their daddies and i just think that
you know that she's an adult your
daughter that if there's some way that
you know i could help you find her or
her find you that
she's always thinking about you i don't
care what anyone says girls don't forget
their dads my dad was absent from my
life for most of my life and there
wasn't a day went by that i didn't think
about him
and at the end of his life he died at 88
at the end of his life when he was like
83 we reconnected and i'm so grateful
for that
i'm so grateful for that and so if you
know if you have the opportunity
to reconnect with your daughter and just
say your piece that you love her and you
wish it was different and that you're
always here moving forward that's a huge
gift for her
no you know i've tried and i think that
people at times think i'm an insensitive
guy and
i want to just clear the air that
1994 five and six
were some of the toughest years of my
life never never mind going to jail
never mind my mom dying never mind just
being confused for [ __ ] 10 years of
your life just it was so tough
and i thought that if i
walked away and did some with my life
because i wasn't winning and i was never
going to win at the pace i was going i
was eventually going to do something end
up in jail and i knew the direction i
was going
uh
and i walked away but the whole time i
had made myself a promise
that if i watch it grow from a distance
and i'm not involved in a life 24 7
i have to make sure i do something in my
life
you know i have to make sure that when i
see her again
that i'll say listen we were apart for
20 years but this is what i did in the
last 20 years
your life wasn't in vain i just didn't
go away and uh forget about you i did
all these things to let you know that i
was working towards this meeting you
know
when i stopped seeing my daughter i had
nothing tanya i had hand to whatever i
made doing comedy i paid her in the
attorney and i shoplifted to take her to
lunch and [ __ ] like that on mon on
wednesdays and sundays it was a horrible
life tanya but i made it work
i made it [ __ ] work and then the
opportunity of eyes with comedy and i
jumped on it and i still tried to keep
in touch i did the best i could
but i had forces outside of me that were
working against me you know her mother
and today look i don't talk to her it's
been a couple years but everything's
been paid off my commitment's been still
there you know over the years i sent
stuff
that was extra you know i sent teddy
bears and i'm sure she never got i mean
tanya the story goes for you know
forever we could sit here for hours but
i just wanted everybody to know and i
appreciate what you were trying to do in
that last conversation we had and i'm
gonna reach out i'm gonna reach out when
the time is right when i get a hold of
her and uh
right now i'm just enjoying mercy and
trying to
get a second chance you know
well you you above anybody deserves that
second chance and anyone who knows you
coco
even just a little bit they know that
you always do the right thing so i have
no doubt that that that you are only
supported and loved and in this in this
whole
you know scenario with your first
daughter and and know that we all love
you and support you and and it's going
to happen the way it's supposed to
happen if you know anything about me it
would be my dream to have them both at
the dinner table with me you know what
i'm saying
and one could tell the other one or the
one could tell you know that would be a
dream come true with my wife
but uh and i would love to even talk to
my ex-wife but i don't think i could
that's one conversation i don't think i
could because it's that
like i told you it's that painful it
wasn't just a divorce
they were trying to cut my legs off
and i'm a bad person yeah there's no
reason for that there's no reason for
that i've done a lot of bad things but
not enough
to cut my legs off like that it was just
a cold-blooded thing that i would never
even do to her and afterwards i did some
things that i regret today i regret them
today as a man but
you make your mistakes and you move on
you know and i'm happy you called tony
and i'm happy that you're in my life
and i'm happy that we talk and uh you're
a [ __ ] savior
you're warmth and you're uh your webpage
and i check on you from time to time i
like on your little facebook page there
and i see that you're you're [ __ ]
hustling you want to sell what you got
and you got something good to sell
well i appreciate that you know i really
feel like after 25 years of practicing i
feel like i do have some good advice to
offer and i love doing it once in one
with my patients that's very fulfilling
and i still do that but you know like i
look online and i've reached you know
like 15 000 people with an article and i
think if i can change if i just change
one of those people's lives for the
better if they made one better decision
because i said something
it makes me feel really good you know i
mean there's so many things working
against us in health you know we get
crappy food and crappy water and crappy
air and we're working or you know
working ourselves to death and not
sleeping and if one thing i say can
change someone's life for the better
then that's what makes it worthwhile for
me you know i really i really am humbled
to have the opportunity to help someone
make up make a better health decision
for sure it's amazing how many times
i've known in life that i've had to make
a decision about something
and i've read somebody's article that i
don't even know i don't even know i know
my best friend is a jiu jitsu [ __ ]
master i got 20 friends that that's all
they do and i took an article by stephen
kepling a guy online
about jiu jitsu about beginning jiu
jitsu that made me join i was just
telling lee you know six years ago when
i made the constant decision to get
healthy i was doing all this stuff at
the gym and cutting my diet i didn't
know what to do and i was frustrated
because in six months i had lost three
pounds
and one day some guy wrote an article
about
dieting is what you do to lose weight
you know like it's not all about working
out just that little simple article
changed everything it made me join
weight watchers so i know that what
you're doing helps people it's like uh
it's like twisting a jar and it doesn't
open and all of a sudden
somebody comes along and just twist it
for you some little kid does it that's
what you do with your writing sometimes
so i'm happy that you're doing that
tanya
i appreciate that we got to get you
emily what's what's the missing link in
your diet what do you think what can i
help you clean up in your diet that that
you think is you know that you know that
you're messing up with that i can give
you some advice on
i was talking to a gentleman at the gym
at justin fortune's gym and he goes
listen joey after 50
a glass of water puts weight on you he
goes you know i gotta watch the sweets
and you really gotta watch this and this
and now you know i'm not blaming nobody
it's me it's me the one that eats the
cheese doodles
it's me that you know i stopped eating
bread but i eat the wheat bread you know
my wife buys coke cuts so i still make a
cheese sandwich with mustard late at
night you know i'm not eating ice cream
or cakes
or stuff like that that's not i'm not
eating i'm not going to restaurants and
eating
it's little things little adjustments i
need to make that's it and i just
realized well you know what you know
what's really scary coco is that 80 of
the food in the grocery store and i'm
not talking dessert like let's forget
about ice cream cookies cakes that's not
included in this eighty percent of the
food has sugar in it that doesn't need
sugar so we're talking pasta sauce
uh marinade salad dressings
everything has sugar and sugar is really
i believe the one diet the one
thing that's in our foods that makes us
fat so you have to read every freaking
label every freaking label um you know
obviously get rid of the soda get rid of
the cakes cookies ice creams but you
have to read things like
can you imagine 80 of the items in the
grocery have sugar in them that don't
need it
and so it's number one it's addictive
number two it's what makes you fat
because your body sugar goes you know
without getting too complicated and
technical basically when you have too
much sugar goes right to fat
so sugars and bread you know sugars even
in wheat bread there's sugar so your
better off is how to eat a cheese
sandwich eat cheese
the heck with the bread it's just
amazing and you know what i go in front
of the house and i work out and i walk
and
i really try to stay on this it's
amazing i haven't had nothing but water
and tea for the last six days straight i
think the other day i was on a plane and
i asked a lady for a diet coke just for
a change
i said let me get a [ __ ] diet coke or
something besides that it's always water
and tea lately just because that's it
that's
so it's not like i'm not trying so it
gets frustrating no i coco i know you're
trying every time i talk to you coming
back from tai chi and acupuncture and
kettlebells i i know that you are
definitely working but there's clearly a
missing link if the numbers are not
going in the right direction
so maybe my advice to you and lee and
your listeners is to really just read
every label and if it says sugar like in
the first five ingredients and sugar is
high fructose corn syrup it's cane syrup
it's maltose i mean i have articles on
that on my website there's like 28 names
for sugar so they mess with you because
if i said sugar you'd know to avoid it
but when it says like maltodextrin you
don't think it's sugar but it is so they
screw with you a lot i just watched the
movie set up um katie couric the girl
from the news she she directed and
produced a movie called set up and it's
about the sugar industry i have to say
it's a little technical but it's really
good and it shows you how messed up you
know messed up our country is that it's
a political there are political reasons
why there's sugar and everything because
the sugar lobbyists they like to sell it
to us you know
so that's that's a good movie to check
out and might help you to understand
you know maybe why you're not dropping
the weight as quickly as you'd like so
you can get it i think you can get it
online but i know it's in theaters now
set up you might want to check that out
even the edibles i eat i look at the
labels with the edibles and i guess and
i tell them at the weed store to tell
the [ __ ] people they make uh edibles
with you know no sugar in them to put
because there's a lot of edibles for
diabetics you know i mean they
they've even gone that far uh cheebachu
is 60 calories
so this ain't killing you this 60
calories don't kill that's one point at
weight watchers you get 44 of those in a
day and an extra 35 of them on sunday so
at one point a day
even if you eat one of these a day it's
seven [ __ ] points it's not gonna kill
you
so i don't know what it is and uh
it's been [ __ ] killing me you know
i'm big and i go to jiu jitsu and listen
no matter how much i stop smoking and i
do cardio
it's 300 [ __ ] pounds
it's 300 pounds every time you [ __ ]
make a move you know there's times i
have to pick the cat litter up for my
wife and they reach like 60 pounds or
something or and i and i go wow this is
what i used to put on my body
this definitely has to [ __ ] my heart you
know so what i really want to do oh and
not only your heart your joints i mean
think about it like you know even if
you're thin and you carry around with
you know 15 pound bag of potatoes that's
you know it's heavy you go geez you know
you put on 15 pounds in the blink of an
eye i mean that's a lot of stress on
your body [ __ ] eyes so i'm going to
try to get out of the 300 club get down
to 299 then go to work from there go
down to 270 go down to 265 just work it
very slowly just wait watch your style
you know just take a little bit off i'm
gonna try to really write everything
down i got a notebook a master notebook
the other day and i'm starting to write
everything down and it's helped it's
really helped a lot so uh that's my next
read the label seriously read the labels
coco because you'll be surprised sugar's
in everything so if you have and i'm not
saying buy sugar-free [ __ ] with the
fake sugar in it don't don't stay away
from the artificial sweeteners just buy
stuff with that's not processed buy
stuff that doesn't have a label you know
you eat an apple you don't need to eat
applesauce with sugar in it you know eat
real food
that's why i love you tanya i'll give
you a call this weekend
i'm happy you got confused i would love
to talk to you
um hey can i ask your listeners check me
out again on facebook it's ask dr tanya
a-s-k-d-r-t-a-n-i-a
if you like what you see
click the like button we'd love to have
you come back your readers are the bomb
you're listening to the bomb they always
write in and
say nice things about me i appreciate it
they're very health conscious people
they're all there's a couple of them
that are chubby that are trying to make
the same move we're making so as long as
they learn something tanya everybody's
[ __ ] happy i love you
love you too coco thanks for having me
back bye-bye mama have a great week
you too bye-bye what's up lee why are
you sitting there all depressed and [ __ ]
i'm not depressed at all you're stoned
to the kills
get up [ __ ]
up chew
that [ __ ] break they put extra in
their first batch like
we were gone for a while let's give them
all the elections you look good though
i'm happy you're looking good you got
red today
you guys don't and it was perfect the
[ __ ] girl scout cookie took you right
into the cheap shoe who's better than me
who takes care of you like uncle [ __ ]
jeffy
you're gonna be walking around in like a
in a tuxedo like you know yeah you know
what it's like the blind people at
restaurants
like i told dr pat of miss paddle i told
you the other day
i'm no [ __ ] jim jam jew you know what
i'm saying what's that mean jim jam jew
i'm no [ __ ] genius you know what i'm
saying i don't know about nothing i know
about [ __ ] like who is this
i know what i [ __ ] did for 30 years i
was a loser dog i did drugs for 30
[ __ ] years so all these drug counts
they could suck my dick you want the
master mix look a little he's chilling
like a [ __ ] doctor
if you close your eyes right now yeah
thought for two minutes beside the sound
of the construction yeah you think
you're a [ __ ] bermuda oh i think
you're sitting there laying there with
the sun somebody's licking your nuts how
good do you feel this is better than the
[ __ ] half a cookie i told you who's
the captain kirk in the [ __ ] company
i gave you the half a cookie to take you
outside of your realm sometimes you
gotta go on the deep end and swim around
but today where are you you're in the
fall you're in four feet of water
nothing could happen to you you're like
a [ __ ] doctor this is nice that's
what the best thing about mondays though
you're a [ __ ] doctor
that's all i'm trying to tell you all
these drug counselors that i can figure
out the problem for you got a coke
problem you hit me up you got an age
problem you hit me the [ __ ] up we'll get
you [ __ ] clean and sober you'll still
be addicted but maybe it'll be a cheaper
choose a lot better than putting a
needle in your [ __ ] arm every week
you know what i'm saying oh i can't even
imagine can you [ __ ] imagine
so what did you think
because this is going to come out after
the the miss pat one
when she said she never used it is that
surprising to you like how can you be
around something like with you who got
hooked on it like what how did that how
did that affect you
listen brother every we're psychopaths
let's get this down i'm a [ __ ]
psychopath okay
uh yeah we're nice people we're all
humans but you gotta break yourself up
and in that craziness we do certain
things i snorted coke
364 days in a year the only day i took
off was new year's eve
you'd think that was my biggest day yeah
but for some [ __ ] reason
i didn't [ __ ] work on new years i
didn't snort coke on new year's [ __ ]
day okay okay new year's eve whatever
the [ __ ] i had little quirks
you know
listen man i broke into people's houses
i sold my soul
you know i robbed drug dealers a lot of
some some kid hit me up the other day
goes i hope you raised your daughter
better than they raised you and robbing
people's hard-earned money you know i
never rob nobody's hard on money you
[ __ ] jerk off i rob drug dealers once
you go into that realm
or anything that goes in with that realm
is [ __ ] legit i'm writing a book the
other day and i and i was writing a
description of who i was in 1984
and i was a loser but my hobby was drugs
and everything that came with it she
even said that she expects to get robbed
like you it's drugs and everything that
comes with it my friend
i never busted into a guys like lee's
house and took his computer and pawned
it i didn't know nothing about that [ __ ]
that's that you know i felt bad that was
my thing i would feel bad if i had a
robbery you know what i'm saying even
though i i kidnapped bella that time
there was a lot of things i wouldn't do
you know all those years i never robbed
a car i always start robbing a car was
the dumbest [ __ ] thing in the world
because you're in it
i can't get out of that mess i'm in the
[ __ ] car with a check or a weapon i
could throw down a [ __ ] thing and buy
me eight hours a time and even if they
find it you could argue wasn't in your
pocket with a car i got no [ __ ]
argument right i'm in it
[ __ ]
so you got to remember there's certain
things
that people will do
and certain things that they won't do
you know hey listen man i was never
[ __ ] i never did sexual tricks for
[ __ ] drugs i never the drug didn't
push me to that
i wasn't like
martin downey jr in uh that one movie
that he did about drugs when he plays
the true you've never seen him from 87.
that's his best part of all time robert
downey
uh he plays a junkie kid
okay
that's his best [ __ ] movie and
there's he's drooling and he has to suck
guys dicks for coke nah i don't know
nothing about that [ __ ] oh i know i know
you never went that far but you know
that world
you do certain things and you have
limitations
and listen i i never really thought i
would kidnap somebody the day i did it i
had limitations
the day i did it that type of
deal i went to prison and let me tell
you something guys i'm not gonna lie to
nobody here
i got in trouble in 88
and 93 i did another drug rip
with some friends of mine and it scared
the [ __ ] out of me like i couldn't
believe i was there again
and i remember getting to the car and
going if i make it home i'm done
and i think two months after that i went
back to colorado to raise jackie that's
a true story that i've never told to
anybody on the podcast or anything no
i've never heard that no i did another
drug group with some guys in new york
and it was so [ __ ] scary and i got no
reason to lie to you guys i was
three minutes from [ __ ] in my pants and
having a heart attack but it wasn't that
i was fear from being there robbing
these guys
it was the fear that i couldn't believe
i was putting myself back in this
position again yeah i could not [ __ ]
believe that after the time
and and i was letting society beat me
and that was one thing at that time i
swear i would not let society beat me
again but if i did blow i'd do it under
the radar but this guy was one of my
goombas
he was one of my friends and i knew that
you know when he came to me i couldn't
say no
and i avoided him i thought he was
[ __ ] me because he was [ __ ] up like
me
but thank god it all worked out and i
moved on and i never put a weapon in my
hand again i never wanted that stuff in
my life again man so
ah it just [ __ ] hurts me talking
about it because it was the most foolish
mistake of my life yeah i mean you must
was it
was it like
did you almost get caught or what no it
wasn't even close you knocked down the
door they were all in the living room we
made them get down
he went through it i didn't have to go
through anything i didn't go through
anybody's pockets i just sat there with
a gun in my hand
if anybody made a move you want to talk
about fear
you want to talk about being [ __ ]
scared guys
just praying that nobody moves praying
because
you might not be scared to shoot him or
you're that stupid
and you do shoot them and these guys
laid there it took [ __ ]
it took [ __ ] four minutes but it felt
like a half hour
and i remember running down those
[ __ ] stairs and all i want to do is
get rid of that [ __ ] gun
that's all i wanted to [ __ ] do was
get rid of that [ __ ] gun man and i
remember getting in the car
and putting the gun and telling him to
drop me off
and him going wine i made up a story
right there in the car because what if
they call the cops and they're looking
for [ __ ] four guys let's break it
down somebody else take a [ __ ] train
too
and i made him drop me over 178 and that
was the end of that
i [ __ ] barely i had maybe like how i
didn't have an aneurysm
on the bus ride over that [ __ ] bridge
back to new jersey
i'll never figure out i'll never [ __ ]
figure out
you talk a lot about how like
being a friend is important and if you
get into something i'll like i'll
support you like that thing
but like i i i don't know the story so i
don't know which friend it is but like
when you like
after that's done
do you get pissed off that your friend
who knows you just got to jail for what
would people put you in that situation
because that doesn't mean i'd be pissed
off at my loyalty
i got pissed off at my loyalty
you know i got pissed off for putting
myself in that situation it wasn't his
fault
i could have been the bigger man but i
also know what i went through with that
kid
i also know what he went through with me
you know and i couldn't say no what if
he had gone and i didn't go and he got
shot
you understand me dog so yeah in my mind
there were so many stupid [ __ ] things
i still love that person until today i
love him i love him till the end of time
he was my brother he was a criminal but
guess what he gave me rides to comedy
games i don't know a lot of [ __ ] com
regular people that give [ __ ] people
rides to comedy gigs when i'm getting no
[ __ ] money right so because of that
that's why i did it because it was many
times i called him and said hey dog i
ain't got a dime and i'm stuck here and
he'd go where yet walk to this corner
i'll be there in 15 [ __ ] minutes
you know so you have to understand i
knew him you know at the time i was uh
maybe 30 yeah and i knew him 15 of those
years it wasn't like some guy bumped
into on the street i knew where he came
from i knew where his house was i knew
where his heart was and i knew that if
the tables were turned around
he'd shoot a [ __ ] for me in a
new york minute it's crazy because like
knowing that puts this pride and there's
love in your heart can't even but also
knowing that i could have done 15 to 20
years for him
puts away right after he got out and no
it was uh let's say i got out in 89
this was either 93 and 94 93 and then
like just
last night you were like why like i was
telling this pen i can't i can't none of
this i can't relate to any of this so
it's not judgment but it's like [ __ ]
like when you said like what if he went
and he got shot when i wasn't there like
oh i can't even i can't imagine
getting into this like okay i get
addicted
if i had to like if i had to rob
somebody to get cheeseburgers i wouldn't
have cheeseburgers anymore i can't being
that addicted but then getting into it
like
okay we can make a little money if we
sell what we have okay we can make more
money if we go and rob this guy i'm like
[ __ ] i can't imagine carrying a gun lee
i wasn't addicted to the coke
i was addicted to the danger oh
everything that came with it i was
addicted to knowing that at any time
somebody could be looking for me that's
right
you don't want to [ __ ] ever pull a
gun if i'm sitting here and tell you
people that i wanted to pull a gun on
people all my life i'm [ __ ] lying to
you i pray to god i'd have to [ __ ]
pull that gun but just knowing that it's
there
knowing that it's [ __ ] there
that whole lifestyle comes with so much
drama but then again it comes with so
much laughter
and so much craziness like i sit here
sometimes now and just [ __ ] laugh
because everything else means nothing
now
i used to walk into a room with guns and
try to put you together to give me
[ __ ] two ounces of coke and walk out
of there now i walk into rooms to do
auditions and i convince you to [ __ ]
give me a role in your stupid movie on
this stupid [ __ ] tv show yeah so
what's the difference what have i
learned it's that guys
it's been a [ __ ] hell of a ride man
you want to judge somebody you [ __ ]
want to judge them hey i'm no [ __ ]
top notch [ __ ] comic i'll let them
and whatever but like i told you
[ __ ] i knew
that if i talked to you guys and told
you where my heart was you'd understand
this is why this is great what we do and
people come out and people email us and
we have a great time because people
understand man so what i made mistakes
so what mrs pat made mistakes we all
[ __ ] made mistakes
now we we we live a great life and we're
telling people
what time telling you lee i told you
something today i haven't told nobody
nobody that i felt [ __ ] horrible
about for 30 [ __ ] years and i didn't
plan on telling you this today i didn't
plan on this this just came out of my
heart today you know so
thank you for watching what do you think
about looking back at it like looking
back at the actions now are you like
that's [ __ ] crazy
like i just like i can't imagine there's
no looking back i just giggle i just
[ __ ] giggle
i i just i'm happy
how do you think
it like i don't maybe it's because i'm
high but like you grew up next like in a
pretty middle-class town and there's
some towns like even let's just say your
town in my town we're only six hours a
probably not that different
how can people grow up so close to each
other
and your life is [ __ ] robbing coke
dealers
and i i could never hold the gun i could
hold the gun but i could never i was
always worried if i put it in my pocket
or holster i never trusted the safety so
i was like i'm just gonna never show
myself but like how does how did two
people like not even like america in
iraq like two people in the same
zip code can grow up totally different
lives
it's the energy it's [ __ ] crazy it's
amazing who you really are when you're
like seven or eight or even 10 or 11 or
12. those are your common core beliefs
when you're 12
you you know when a kid is 13 you're
like what are you going to be i'm going
to be a cop and he's kind of goofy or
whatever but you have common little
beliefs then and i have those beliefs
again after i stopped doing drugs and
started full i got my beliefs back and i
realized i couldn't carry a gun that's
how i knew i wasn't it's not that i was
crazy because if i was still crazy i'd
carry a gun
it was just a weakness in my heart at
the time
it was just you get these holes in your
[ __ ] heart from time to time and you
have to fill them and once you fill them
all then
then you know you can move forward i
wasn't prepared to move forward i had
all these holes in my game man and that
was one of them that was one of them
robbing drug dealers that was one of
them doing drugs that was one of them
you know all those years the people i
was hanging out with were my friends
there was a lot of people in that core
that were my [ __ ] blood they were my
blood
so i want you to understand that i was
with family when i was in colorado doing
that dumb [ __ ] i was with jimmy burkley
a lot of times so i had blood in the
area you know
i don't even know what the [ __ ] i'm
saying [ __ ] on it you bad [ __ ]
i can't say enough good things about
honor i can't say enough good things
about them i feel great when i can tell
the difference now when i don't use the
the shroom tech sport and when i use it
sometimes when i go to jiu jitsu or the
kettlebells or the epileptic i take one
aspirin and two [ __ ] uh
uh on it and sometimes i i just take the
baby aspirin and go i could feel the
difference shroom tech if you're looking
to get into something you're looking for
more cardiovas you're looking for not
that energy thing you get from your
[ __ ] energy drinks then it drops i'm
talking about after the 30 minute drop
of rolling or lifting or doing the
epileptic or those last 20 minutes
because your body doesn't start burning
fat till 20 minutes or 18 to 20 minutes
after that that time
you know you have another 20 minutes
after that 40 minutes where are you
going are you are you tired you have
more energy try the schum tech sport if
it works for a 300 [ __ ] pound guy in
the epileptical past 40 minutes it'll
[ __ ] definitely work for you not only
that they got alpha brain they got
[ __ ] kettlebells they got ropes
they've got instructional [ __ ] dvds
they've got risk for your kettlebells so
if you do kettlebells you don't hurt
your wrist but i i specialize the most
in their nutrients all that stuff is
[ __ ] tremendous for you the
turnaround the hemp forest protein
powder i cannot say greater things about
i hate to taste the [ __ ] protein but
the chocolate from [ __ ] on it is
[ __ ] delicioso [ __ ] go to on
it when they press in the box church
church c-h-u-r-c-h
try them out you get 10 off you get put
on the mailing list while we're not
[ __ ] around one thing i do have at
the house and i do eat from time to time
very low calorie all-natural not that
much sugar naturesbox.com
you get 50 off your first order order
for father's day trust me dad don't like
this [ __ ] what do you got to lose take a
chance columbus did right or wrong order
it get the sesame sticks the the [ __ ]
black and white granola i can't wait to
get it again the black and white granola
was so [ __ ] delicious my wife and the
baby were eating it the apple figs
delicious the cocoa almonds delicious do
me a favor go to naturesbox.com read
what they're about read the nutrients
read what the [ __ ] they do and what
their mission is from their order i'm
telling you the first time 50 off 50 off
the first order if you want to order
from there you do what you want to do if
you don't go back to potato chips i
don't give a [ __ ] but try these things
you're going to love it what's the third
jelly go to joeydiaz.net go to nature's
box
box and press jelly boom j-o-e-y get 50
off your first order do you understand
me i ain't [ __ ] around with you also
again i want to congratulate those
people up there nailed their life
they're putting posters of the baby up
every day on facebook the baby it's
[ __ ] adorable we had a batman cape on
a superman cape on i love you guys up
there david i love you [ __ ]
what you're doing whether it's those
gummies or mono's whether it's the vapor
pen from [ __ ] depth it's one of the
best vapor pens on the market when you
mention joey diaz you get what twenty
percent off are you kidding me or what
where did they get this discount at now
live.com they ain't [ __ ] around
tremendous vaping can't bend it either
burns the oil or the [ __ ]
wax
for all you [ __ ] that want to
see the devil full-time who doesn't also
escape mytank.com i'm giving these guys
an extra [ __ ] shout out this week
because they are the [ __ ] masters of
what they do i'm getting emails from
people going joey you know what i
haven't bought a tank yet but i looked
into it i could save [ __ ] 4 200 i
could do this i could do that they're a
tremendous [ __ ] company with
tremendous cup comes to my service you
contact [ __ ] what's his name jeremy
on the 800 line bam he answers the phone
good morning this is jeremy how can i
help you i'll answer all your questions
they'll ship it to you direct they have
financing available if you order the
just the tank model you got 150 off if
you mention joey coco d is the podcast
flying jews black [ __ ] black women
with big asses boom they'll give you an
additional 250 percent off you can't
lose dollars huh they can't give you 250
percent i don't know
maybe we can figure out a way to get
jeremy's a good [ __ ] dude call him up
on the 809 if you have any questions
about flotation tanks uh shipping
handling uh people building it you know
building the box for you because he has
residential commercial industrial
don't write this girl let's say you have
a tanning salon take a chance put a
[ __ ] thing in there what do you got
to lose let's say you have a [ __ ]
massage party you got women's sucking
dick think about after somebody sucks
your dick you put them in the flow
checkation too they'll be back the
following week with a finger up the ass
and the [ __ ]
i'm just dropping ideas to you let's say
you let's say you do let's say you're a
dick sucker in your home and you're
sucking dick and giving a massage call
jeremy get a flotation tank you throw
the [ __ ] victims in the flotation
tank afterwards let them get their head
together nobody does that that's the
extra step if you're going to be a
professional maybe they can figure out a
way to give you your colonoscopy in the
tank
it was the last time i hit in the head
with a [ __ ]
where's my song today it's monday
[ __ ]
little tony bennett i want to be around
out of respect i love you guys i ain't
going nowhere we're just playing some
music here for you having a good time on
the church today it's monday
the 9th of june you bad [ __ ]
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what time
for a vape
so
it's monday we got another list you got
another package all you gotta do is take
a walk right from here i got direct tv
what time
3 8 noon
no no 12 4 12 4. cut it out you got to
know where to go put the music on do a
fake
what's that what is that a little girl
vape almost no no do the [ __ ] vape
the right you hold it in your mouth i
saw it
you want to see it expanding your lungs
and your belly push it and then go slow
slow slow that's a boy
hold it
there you go there you go one more one
more for the communists
listen look at the [ __ ] shape
let's see
if the puzzle
fits you bad [ __ ] monday get it
together wash your feet clean your
[ __ ] you don't want to be out there
stinking up the [ __ ] joint then you
wonder why you got no friends
are you kidding me or what turn that off
cox i'm never kidding
it's a beautiful day to be alive so we
did man pat last night miss pat and then
you got tanya today we did our thing we
won't see you till next [ __ ] monday
now [ __ ] that's how i roll maybe
we'll do something wednesday i don't
know see how the jew feels
okay we'll see how the jew feels
look at the shape of you
i was telling you guys a couple weeks on
a live podcast if you listen to the last
one from the ice house was it rick
shapiro oh no it was ari sophia it was
aries sofia that uh
i always felt lawrence fishburne was the
best [ __ ] black actor
and i wanted to prove my point this
morning you can't watch it unless you're
watching live you could see it you could
hear it this is the opening scene
from the king of new york a little gift
for you [ __ ]
if you want to watch it with us i mean
not if you're watching live but if
you're listening just pause it and go to
it's called king of new york intro drug
deal uncut and i'm going to start it at
21 seconds all right guys check this
[ __ ] [ __ ] out all right i love you
guys see you uh next monday please stay
black do what the [ __ ] you want to do
grab your balls it's monday tell them
all to suck your dick it's your [ __ ]
world all right no no put the thing on
just in case
calm down all right relax yeah i'm going
to show you how to do this
right
it's dope tito
yo man you forget the feeling you was
being watched
got any uh soda man
like some root beer something i heard my
leg playing ball man i got these aspects
i want to take you know
what the [ __ ] is he i'm gonna tell him
to turn this [ __ ] off what kind of help
you got man watching cartoons tell my
man to turn the tv off and get me a sort
of uncle
please
yeah and make sure it's cold
i like my [ __ ] cold man especially when
i'm playing ball man you play ball tito
no you don't look like you're playing a
ball but yo nice gloves though i like
those
jump
yeah what's up
expectations
oh
you're the king
where's my shoulder
the [ __ ] is this
bullet hole
tremendous service [ __ ]
room service [ __ ]
so if you're bored and you want to see a
real [ __ ] movie this weekend
on your own just watch king of new york
for a little while and watch lauren's
fish burns acting he looks so [ __ ]
young he's like well smith he's [ __ ]
badass in this and you got the wesley
snipes is in this you got a red dog is
in this the guy from my csi miami you've
got tremendous actors and there's a
couple character actors you might see
great [ __ ] movie christopher walken
tremendous the attorney is badass she
looks a little like felicia the attorney
in this movie a little bit like felicia
yeah
so watch the movie there you go you got
a complete podcast for you got a whole
week to [ __ ] meditate on these things
we got miss pat we got today's we got
[ __ ] roblox we got gabriel we love
you [ __ ] all right have a great
week stay black don't let nobody [ __ ]
with you don't let nobody [ __ ] with you
all right you got a dream [ __ ] them all
i'm gonna suck your dick you're the
baddest [ __ ] in the room when
you walk in i don't give a [ __ ] what
they tell you strap a [ __ ] pair on
[ __ ] it's monday you're taking
somebody [ __ ] down today drop it lee
now that the show's over remember to go
to naturebox.com in order great tasting
healthy snacks at 50 off 50 cup suckers
now today it's the next murder in the
new year with healthy and delicious
treats like everything bagel chips and
sriracha cashews uh support this podcast
and get 50 off of your first order go to
naturebox.com promo code joey that's
nature's box.com joey go to nailed it
live.com to get the premier vapor friend
on the mark that's joey diaz and get 20
go to escape tank.com and call it or
call jeremy the 800 number and he'll
save you 250 off of uh flotation tank
and thank you onyx.com for all of your
brain supplements and every battle ropes
and
all that i'm gonna choke you one of them
[ __ ] play the music we
i was proud of myself watching muscle on
top of my
it's all about you at the end of